Traduttore: Daria Aloisi
Revisore: Anisa Fezga
Io sono qui a parlarvi di felicità
che, come vedete dal titolo,
è una cosa seria.
Cominciamo,
prima di iniziare letteralmente,
con un piccolo sondaggio.
Alzi la mano
chi è felice in questo momento.
Oh! Vi vedo belli carichi!
Sono contento! Grazie per le luci.
Sono convinto che
la risposta sarebbe più difficile
se io vi chiedessi quanto siete felici.
Io sono un'economista
mi occupo, in particolare,
di misurazione della felicità
e della qualità della vita.
Noi economisti abbiamo
una deformazione professionale:
diamo i numeri!
Letteralmente diamo i numeri
cioè mettiamo un numero
a tutto ciò che misuriamo.
In economia, la felicità
viene associata al benessere;
il benessere viene associato al denaro;
e, quindi, normalmente in economia,
la felicità è monetizzata
secondo l'implicita equazione per cui
più denaro ho
e più felicità sono in grado di comprare.
Se questa è la storia
io devo farvi un'altra domanda,
una domanda che sarà fondamentale
per il resto della vostra esistenza.
E questa domanda è la seguente:
cosa succede al PIL,
il prodotto interno lordo di una nazione
se un professore sposa la sua cuoca?
Potrà sembrarvi
una domanda stupida, banale.
Io prometto che vi darò
la risposta a questa domanda
nel corso del mio intervento.
Vi posso dire che questa domanda
è stata fatta diversi anni fa
da un premio Nobel per l'economia,
Paul Samuelson,
in una conferenza
non troppo diversa da questa.
Prima, però, di arrivare alla risposta
a questa domanda,
io devo raccontarvi un'altra storia,
che, sono convinto,
molti di voi conosceranno già.
E' una storia che arriva
da Siddharta di Hermann Hesse,
ed è la storia dell'elefante
e dei sei saggi ciechi.
In un villaggio indiano,
arriva un elefante
che deve essere descritto da questi saggi,
che sono ciechi.
Quindi, cosa succede?
A seconda di qual è la parte
dell'elefante che viene toccata
l'elefante sembra una cosa
completamente diversa.
L'orecchio sembra un ventaglio,
la coda sembra un serpente,
la proboscide sembra una corda,
la zampa una colonna,
il corpo dell'elefante sembra un muro.
Tutti i saggi,
e nessuno allo stesso tempo,
hanno ragione, perché l'elefante
è più della somma delle sue componenti.
E con la felicità
funziona più o meno allo stesso modo.
La felicità è un ombrello
sotto cui stanno tante dimensioni.
A seconda di come
decidiamo di misurare la felicità
vediamo cose diverse.
Come misuriamo la felicità,
influenza come vediamo le società.
Vi faccio subito un esempio.
Quella che vedete alle mie spalle
è la classifica dei 10 paesi al mondo
che stanno meglio,
secondo due indicatori molto diversi.
A sinistra c'è la classifica di felicità
misurata dal World Happiness Report
dell'ONU
un'iniziativa che dal 2012,
misura la felicità per i paesi nel mondo.
A destra c'è la classifica
secondo il reddito medio pro-capite,
quindi il PIL, prodotto interno lordo.
Come vedete,
le due classifiche sono molto diverse.
Ora, la felicità a una dimensione,
rimanendo nella metafora
della storia dell'elefante
di cui viene toccato solo un pezzo,
come si misura?
In parte vi ho già risposto.
L'indicatore principe,
utilizzato per misurare la felicità
a una dimensione,
è il Prodotto Interno Lordo.
Cos'è il Prodotto Interno Lordo?
Questa è la definizione
dal libro di testo:
"Si definisce come
il valore dei beni e servizi finali,
prodotti in una economia,
in un certo intervallo di tempo,
che, normalmente, è un anno".
Cerchiamo di andare
un po' più dentro questa definizione.
"Valore" ci dice subito che
il PIL è misurato in moneta,
secondo qual è la valuta del paese
che si sta considerando.
"Beni e servizi" ci dice che
il PIL comprende beni materiali
ma anche servizi,
per esempio una cena a un ristorante.
Finale molto importante:
immaginate un paese in cui
ci sono soltanto due aziende,
una produce automobili
e una produce acciaio.
Quella che produce automobili
usa l'acciaio
prodotto dalla seconda azienda.
Nel PIL finisce a essere contato
solo il reddito
che deriva dalla rendita delle automobili,
perché, in questo caso,
l'acciaio è un bene intermedio
e finirebbe per essere contato due volte.
Ora il PIL, prodotto interno lordo,
è un po' sulla bocca di tutti,
e a buona ragione:
perchè ha degli aspetti positivi
e delle criticità.
Da un punto di vista positivo,
è un ottimo indicatore
di prosperità economica.
Cosa significa?
E' una fotografia,
un'istantanea molto precisa
della salute produttiva di un paese,
in un certo istante di tempo.
Inoltre il PIL ha il pregio
di essere sintetico,
un numero solo rende molto semplice
i confronti tra paesi diversi
e per lo stesso paese
lungo la dimensione temporale.
Infine il PIL è associato positivamente
a dimensioni che normalmente,
consideriamo correlate
alla qualità della vita.
Cosa vuol dire?
Paesi con un PIL elevato
di solito,
sono paesi
in cui le persone sono più sane;
sono più istruite,
e la qualità delle istituzioni è migliore.
Va tutto bene?
Sì e No.
Perché ci sono anche delle criticità.
La prima è che
il PIL è come se fosse
la busta paga di una nazione.
Niente di male ma,
voi dite di una persona che è ricca
solo guardando la sua busta paga?
Non penso.
Infatti se andate in banca
a chiedere un prestito
la banca non si accontenterà mai
solo della vostra busta paga,
vuole conoscere
la vostra situazione patrimoniale.
Il PIL, invece, non misura
la situazione patrimoniale di un paese,
è un flusso di produzione.
In secondo luogo il PIL,
questo fu detto in un celebre discorso
di Bob Kennedy nel 1968,
esclude dal suo computo
alcune variabili
che sicuramente producono valore
per la nostra esistenza
ma non sono monetizzate.
Il gioco dei nostri bambini,
la bellezza delle nostre poesie,
non sono incluse nel PIL,
eppure producono valore
e fanno una vita felice.
Viceversa, il PIL include al suo interno
delle variabili che sono monetizzate,
che, però, è difficile pensare
siano associate
ad un miglioramento
della qualità della vita.
Una su tutte la spesa per divorzi.
Se una coppia si separa
e deve pagare un avvocato divorzista,
quel reddito diventa PIL.
Però è opinabile che
la fine di un amore possa essere visto
come miglioramento
di ricchezza di un paese.
Ora, questo mi consente
di farvi vedere questo grafico
che mostra quanto la relazione
tra reddito e felicità
sia una cosa complessa.
Questo grafico arriva da una ricerca
di metà anni settanta
di un ricercatore americano,
Richard Easterlin,
che mostrò, sostanzialmente,
la relazione tra reddito pro capite medio
per i paesi del mondo
e felicità misurata secondo questionari
in cui si chiede alle persone
quanto sono felici in un scala da 1 a 10.
Quello che si vede da questo grafico è che
all'aumentare del reddito
la felicità aumenta.
Ma, arrivati a una certa soglia,
la felicità non cresce
proporzionalmente con il reddito.
C'è come un livello di saturazione
oltre il quale la relazione tra reddito
e felicità non è così lineare
e questo produce dei paradossi.
Questi paradossi sono diversi,
e uno ha reso l'Italia celebre nel 2014
perché l'ISTAT,
l'Ufficio Statistico Nazionale,
ha vinto il prestigiosissimo premio
Ig Nobel per l'economia.
Non sto scherzando!
Che ogni hanno viene assegnato
dalla prestigiosa università di Harvard.
Perché è stato dato il premio Ig Nobel
per l'economia all'ISTAT?
Recependo una direttiva comunitaria,
l'ISTAT ha stabilito che
nel PIL italiano vanno contati i proventi,
i redditi che derivano
dal traffico di stupefacenti,
e dal mercato della prostituzione.
Significa che il più del PIL
associato a queste attività
viene identificato come
un miglioramento della ricchezza;
ma è opinabile che queste attività
siano associate a un miglioramento
della qualità della vita di un paese.
Il secondo paradosso
mi permette, finalmente,
di rispondervi alla domanda
da cui sono partito.
Cosa succede al PIL di una nazione
quando un professore sposa la sua cuoca?
Partiamo dall'inizio.
Un professore assume una cuoca.
Deve essere molto ricco
questo professore!
Se l'assume le farà un contratto regolare,
le pagherà uno stipendio.
Quello stipendio e reddito
entrerà nel PIL, come un flusso positivo.
I due si innamorano.
E se desiderano coronare
il loro sogno d'amore,
sposandosi ad esempio,
è auspicabile che il professore
rompa il contratto con sua moglie.
Se lo rompe,
quella non è più una transazione,
non è più un reddito,
e, quindi, il PIL è associato
a un segno meno.
Ma la domanda è:
possibile che in questo caso
la nascita di un amore
venga misurata
come un peggioramento
della qualità della vita di una nazione?
Se la felicità a una dimensione
presenta alcune criticità
che abbiamo visto,
come si fa a misurare la felicità
a più dimensioni?
Qui prima abbiamo criticato L'ISTAT
per il premio Ig Nobel per l'economia,
ora è bene, invece, tesserne le lodi.
Perché l'ISTAT
è all'avanguardia in Europa
con un progetto che, dal 2013,
vuole integrare la contabilità nazionale
attraverso un diverso approccio
alla misurazione del benessere.
Questo progetto si chiama BES.
BES è un acronimo
che sta per benessere equo e sostenibile.
In sostanza,
l'obiettivo è quello di misurare
il benessere di una nazione
non più con un solo numero, il reddito,
ma con un sistema di indicatori,
sono 134,
raccolti lungo 12 dimensioni,
che sono quelle
che vedete alle mie spalle,
all'interno delle quali
c'è anche il reddito,
ma ce ne sono molte altre:
c'è la salute, c'è l'istruzione,
c'è il lavoro,
ci sono le relazioni sociali,
la politica, la sicurezza,
il benessere soggettivo, il paesaggio,
l'ambiente, la ricerca,
la qualità dei servizi.
Ora, come nella storia dell'elefante
tutte queste dimensioni
compongono il benessere,
ma non una indipendentemente dalle altre.
Io concludo il mio intervento
citandovi un'altra ricerca
che è diventata celebre
perché è stata pubblicata
da due premi Nobel per l'economia,
Daniel Kahneman e Angus Deaton,
che hanno utilizzato
dei dati americani della Gallup
per studiare
la relazione tra reddito e felicità
e stimare la soglia critica.
Cioè qual è quel numero magico,
quel reddito oltrepassato il quale
il reddito non compra più la felicità?
Questo numero magico, per gli Stati Uniti,
è identificato, è stimato essere
75000 dollari annui,
oltre il quale reddito
la felicità non si muove più
con il reddito.
All'aumentare della ricchezza
non aumenta la felicità.
La domanda
con cui vi lascio è questa:
noi siamo in grado di stimare
la nostra soglia critica
oltre la quale
il reddito non compra più la felicità?
Io credo e spero di sì.
Con questa speranza e convinzione,
e con questa bellissima vignetta
dei Peanuts,
vi auguro di essere
vergognosamente felici.
Grazie!